(upbeat rock music)
- Hey guys, I'm Scott,
I'm a Tasty producer
and I've been challenged by Brenda
to make a 100-layer crepe cake.
Last season, we had a producer
made a 100-layer lasagna
and when you hear that,
you would guess there's
100 lasagna noodles,
but he counted, like,
the sauce, bechemel...
When I'm gonna make 100-layer crepe cake,
there's going to be one-hund-red crepes.
Let's get started.
We made a lot of crepes on Tasty.
This rainbow one is amazing, wow.
- [Brenda] Oh, imagine
doing 100 different colors.
- I'm not doing that. (both laugh)
- [Brenda] What's that filling?
- I think its just whipped cream.
We've got our recipe,
let's get our ingredients.
Go, go, go!
It's like I'm on Top Chef or something.
Flour, sugar, salt!
- [Brenda] You got 10 seconds.
- I, that's all there is!
- [Brenda Alright.
- Alright.
Two tablespoons of butter,
the milk, and eggs,
we'll whisk that together, also--
(glass shatters)
Ah!
- [Brenda] Aw,
it looks like a sad omelet.
- Crepe one, pretty bad.
Not, oh--
- [Brenda] Whoo, you got it!
- Oh, nice!
We've made four and
it's been half an hour.
I wanna get one of my favorite crepe cakes
in the city and sort of dissect it,
make sure that my crepe
tastes like their crepe.
Alright, this is the best
crepe cake in New York
and there was a sign in there that said
there were 20 paper thin layers of crepe.
They're not counting
the filling as a layer,
so it seems like we're on the right track
counting 100 crepes..
- It's mostly filling.
- Yeah, it's like a sweetened whip cream
and just a so delicate
and thin of a crepe.
I think this was good research.
- [Brenda] Yes.
- I think I need
to make my crepes thinner
- [Brenda] Okay.
- I think...
That's all I really learned. (both laugh)
We're back, day two.
I feel like I'm pretty
good going into today.
Yesterday we used three eggs,
today we're gonna use 24 eggs.
One of our Tasty writers made a post,
how to make a perfect crepe
according to a French person,
so now we're gonna take her recipe,
scale that up to a hundred
and make a crepe cake.
This is the biggest bowl we
have in the Tasty kitchen.
I don't know how I'm
gonna get this in there.
(egg cracks)
(playful flute music)
Wow, so many eggs.
I could use about seven more
people to help with this.
(playful flute music)
Add the cooled butter.
- [Brenda] Ooh...
- What?
I feel good about this.
My hand is like, I can't actually
straighten my hand anymore.
This looks right, this
looks like as creamy
as it's supposed to look.
We're gonna let this set for an hour.
I think we're in a good place.
Not perfect, ah, we're getting there!
We were so close, nice!
I need a paper and a pen and we need
to just start tallying these up.
Yes, oh!
- [Brenda] No!
- It's still usable.
(both gasp)
What?
- [Brenda] How?
- [Scott] That is a good crepe.
- Whoa, hold on.
- [Scott] Go, go, go, go, go!
- This is scary.
Oh my god, Scott, this is, I'm sorry.
- 50 crepes!
(Brenda claps)
- [Brenda] That was the
saddest celebration.
- Let me know when we're at a hundred.
This is the 99th crepe.
Wow, my heart is racing.
Number 100, comin' atcha.
(crepe lands)
(applause)
- [Woman] That's it!
- [All] Yay!
- Alright, it's day
three, we made 100 crepes.
We've had a bit of an oversight here.
So it's not supposed to
be just whipped cream,
it needs to be a pastry cream, that way,
when all this weight is on top of it,
it just doesn't squeeze out.
We have to make a huge
batch of pastry cream
and then we also wanna make four flavors.
Do you have any advice
on, like, how to tackle
making these four flavors?
I'm thinking, based on how I know
to make pastry cream,
mix in butter and vanilla
when it's hot at the end, would you get
like a stockpot
- [Jesse] Yes.
- [Scott] And just make pastry cream?
- Yes, just make one big pastry cream.
(laid back drum beat)
And then, for strawberry,
I would get a jam
and then chocolate, just literally chop up
some chocolate and throw
it in when it's hot
and then it'll melt
and you can fold it in.
Vanilla, I'd just add
paste, vanilla bean paste
or even extract and matcha,
when it's still hot,
I would put it in, like,
a fine sieve or a strainer
and then do this and then
fold it in and do this
and fold it and it should be fine.
(laid back drum beat)
- [Scott] I think it's all gonna have
we'll add vanilla extract
to the overall cream
and we'll kinda keep that...
- [Jesse] Just leave
that one plain then?
- [Scott] Leave
that one plain.
(goofy classical music)
(tape tears loudly)
Oh my gosh!
- [Brenda] Is that a,
what the heck is this?
- Something Vaughn said yesterday
really stuck with me, he said I wasn't
being original or big enough.
I'm not in the business
of not going all out.
If we assemble this crepe
cake, it's just gonna
be this Leaning Tower of Pisa situation.
This is, like, cute, it's a crepe.
This, tell me we shouldn't be doing this.
You know what I have to do.
Oh, it's tearing!
This will go to the crepe graveyard.
No, this is terrible.
- [Brenda] Scott, that's awesome!
That looks really good!
Oh!
- Wow!
(peaceful marimba music)
I may have lost track of what day,
exactly, it is.
We spent a lot of time
with the giant crepe maker.
I'm not gonna be satisfied if we go
with the smaller one and yesterday,
Brenda got me this guy.
It makes them perfectly
thin, it uses less batter.
We've got 100 crepes to make, let's do it!
(peaceful marimba music)
I am 900% crepe right now.
(sighs) Oh my god, I lost count again.
Nobody is here! (laughs)
I think I'm losing it.
I don't think this was designed to be on
for this amount of time,
so I'm overall impressed
that it's still working.
Sometimes, life gives you crepes.
(cricket chirping)
You gotta make...
Good crepes and bad crepes.
That's not a saying.
This is number...
Almost 90.
This is taking a lot longer
than I thought it would,
it's very late, nobody is here.
Here we go. (sighs)
(pants and whispers) Yes!
(normal voice) Here we
go, bringing in 90, ah!
Oh, f--
Okay, 90's not beautiful, but that's fine.
This is our last crepe.
(chuckles) I'm losin' it.
(sizzling)
(whispers) Hurry up, crepe.
I think it's done, which means I'm done.
For today at least!
At least when I made the first 100 crepes,
there was like a room that
fake applauded for me.
(applause)
Nobody's here to celebrate with me.
We did it, we got a giant crepe cake,
hundred layer coming soon.
Whoo!
This is it, I'm going to
work, this is our last day
of the hundred layer giant crepe cake.
I stayed after last night
to make all the fillings.
This is it, this is the last day,
make or break.
(cool drum beat)
This is gonna be amazing.
Alright, this is 49, one more
and we're halfway there.
- I'm about to start crying.
- You're about to start crying?
- This adventure's almost done.
- Still don't know if
the other pastry creams
have firmed up, hopefully.
- [Brenda] What layer is this?
- Honestly, Brenda, I don't know. (laughs)
This is 50.
We are officially
- [Brenda] Whoo!
- Halfway done.
(upbeat inspiring music)
This is number 99! (screams)
Number 100!
[Scott And Brenda] Whoo!
Thank you, wow, I'm lightheaded!
We're gonna throw this guy in the freezer,
dust it with some powdered sugar later,
and then we'll cut it and we'll serve it
and it's gonna be grand.
(upbeat dance music)
- [Brenda] Okay, it's cutting pretty well!
- Oh, I feel every layer,
it's so satisfying!
- [Brenda] (gasps) Oh my god! (laughs)
- I don't know!
What in the actual world?
- That's insane!
- [Scott] Can we get that in the freezer?
- Yeah, seriously, oh!
(Scott gasps)
Scott, you're just gonna have
to cut another one.
You're just gonna have
to, okay, I'm leaving.
I'm gonna leave this production right now,
so Scott's gonna be by himself.
Oh no, Scott, I'm so sorry!
- Let's just try again.
- Yeah!
We still gotta eat it.
(upbeat music)
- Steven's here to inspect if I actually
got 100 layers, which I did,
so I don't know why he's here.
- One, two, three, four.
(sped-up squeaking)
99, 100!
(Scott and Brenda whoop)
- Scott just gave birth, he's a new mom.
(Scott whistling)
- [Scott] Giant crepe cake coming through.
It's so heavy.
We've got four flavors,
chocolate, strawberry,
matcha and vanilla.
Does anyone want some?
(everyone laughs)
We did it, we conquered
the 100-layer crepe cake
and it was cool, to see how, when I sent
the message to the office,
people did come down.
It is the biggest, craziest
thing I've ever made.
I think we made some people happy
and that's what really matters.
This piece is much too large. (laughs)
(laid back bass vibe)
(camera clicks)